hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control PE dot
l2-3.10.6 enforce safeguarding measures
for cui at alternate work sites this is
a good one
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
is feeling overwhelmed tired and alone
it's sad
trying to understand all this cmmc dfars
and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff on
top of it already Mount Fuji size
colossal workload well I've got great
news for you you found your home here at
on-call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on-call compliance Hero Let's
jump into it so uh the inevitable
scenario here is that we have work that
needs to go on outside of our secure
buildings yes it happens and what it
does we have to account for it and
should have a policy in place yes that's
a hint that will dictate how we are
safeguarding cui when at alternate work
sites in case you didn't hear the hint
the hint is policy now I will tell you
we solved this for our clients with
training and we have created an actual
policy and standard operating procedure
called the alternate worksite policy
that's how we solve it if you're one of
our clients we take the time to walk you
through it and we work together to
customize it entirely for your
organization so you meet this control
that's the kind of stuff that we help
our clients with okay let's check out
what the assessors are looking for on
this one so uh first thing you're
looking for determine if safeguarding
measures for cui are defined for
alternate work sites again where do you
define that stuff right it's a policy so
again a sample answer might be the
company's it use and cyber security
policy provides safeguarding measures
for alternate work sites again it's a
really simple answer there next one
determine if safeguarding measures for
cui are enforced for alternate work
sites implement the company's it use and
cyber security policy provides
safeguarding measures for alternate work
sites example MFA multi-factor
authentication is required when working
at alternate works sites that's an
example of it
so hey and on call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this dfar's nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped into their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day baby we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps great areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you you can visit
cmfccompliancecrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better Hulk smash that subscribe
button right now to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance turns roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
thank you